a lot of people when they hear the word
influence or persuasion
the image that comes to mind is of a
smarmy car salesman kind of person
that's absolutely repulsive to us on
every single level and the influence
skills that i teach
are influence skills that can help you
get what you want and make a bigger mark
in the world and if you remember nothing
else at all from today that people are
two or three times more likely to say
yes
when we ask them for help when we make
an in-person request than we think that
they are
just ask and it rarely matters how
so
the first key force of influence is
called i call it moments of truth
proctor and gamble actually are the
marketing department there coined this
phrase
and this is just
reminding you
to keep in mind to ask
at the best time that that person will
be most receptive to say yes
so it could be
they're most excited about you it could
be
they just got a bunch of money it could
be this is the time when you're supposed
to ask like if it's an annual review
that's when you're supposed to ask for
what's the next step
in my job but you can also think about
moments of truth in more creative ways
like when will people be caring the most
about the topic that you have
to offer them or to ask them for so this
is an example of procter and gamble's
laundry team in beirut this is like tied
and they wrote it's called bonux and
they wanted to market this laundry
detergent
and they were thinking about moments of
truth because that's how they roll they
know how important it is but they go
well when are people going to be
thinking about laundry detergent
when are they most likely to be
interested in laundry detergent really
laundry detergent's not that interesting
so we don't think about it that often so
when do we think about laundry detergent
probably when we're doing laundry
and kind of that's it
so are television ads going to be a good
way to reach people when they're doing
laundry
no
radio ads not even how do you reach
people when they're doing laundry
well in beirut
most people live in tall apartment
buildings and they have a washing
machine they don't have a dryer and then
they hang their laundry out to dry on
the balcony
and what the brilliant marketing team
realized was that they could reach
people doing their laundry by putting
ads
on the tops of buses
so
this ladies and gentlemen is a moment of
truth
labeling
is naming a behavior
and you can name a behavior that you
want to encourage or you can name a
behavior that you want to discourage
so these researchers who were testing
the power of labels they were in cahoots
at this elementary school with the
principal and the custodian and the
teachers and in half of the classroom
all of those people said this to the
kids they said you should be neat and
tidy
and it serves as a reminder of something
the kids know
and it doubles the amount of litter that
gets thrown in the trash can instead of
left in the classrooms for the other
half of the classroom
classrooms they said to the kids you are
neat and tidy and this is the label
this is this is telling the kids how
they are
and it's a positive label that gets them
to step up and be closer to their best
self and in this case they more than
quintupled the amount of litter that the
kids are throwing in the trash so this
is the power of a positive label to get
someone to step into that better self
that you see them as you can also use a
negative label this is direct
condom company
to all those who use our competitors
products
whether a label is negative or positive
obviously depends on where you're coming
from
father
usually a positive label
not always
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
zoe chance and my take on her top 10
rules of success
enjoy
rule number two harness the power of
ease i want to share with you the most
under appreciated and under famous
marketing metric
even if you're not in marketing though
we can take inspiration from this and
the power of ease and it's called the
customer effort score
much less famous than customer
satisfaction and net promoter score if
you don't know what net promoter score
is it's fine it doesn't really matter
it's basically word of mouth and it's
very widely used
it turns out that customer effort score
is more predictive of spending and
loyalty than either of these two metrics
and it's far simpler
it's just one question
the question is how much effort
did you have to make
in this transaction or in this situation
and if you take this to heart
and put this to work in your business
absolutely you will transform your
business and your profitability
all you have to ask yourself and your
employees and your customers
to harness the power of ease
is how can we make it easier to take
action
and then how can we make it even easier
than that rule number three change
behavior not mind this is a
distinction that most of us don't make
we think that if we want to change
somebody
we need to change their mind but so
little
of our thinking and our behavior is
actually happening consciously or
intentionally
that
often it's not just that it's so so hard
to change people's minds including yours
of course as you know but it is
very unlikely that if you do change
their minds their behavior will just
naturally follow
and a simple example of conversation
somebody was having me with having with
me this morning is about his kid not
rinsing out the
bathroom sink after brushing his teeth
and he's like how do i
how do i get him to care
how do i get him to remember and he
thinks he needs to change his son's mind
but
he's just forgetting it's not that his
son needs to be motivated to
rinse out the sink right
motivation
even though this is such a big part of
what we talk about in our pursuit of
success
motivation
is a smaller part of the question than
just making it easy
so i was talking about what would make
it easier for your son to remember to do
the thing and so he's going to ask his
son
what would it take for you to remember
to do the thing and they'll decide you
know is it going to be a hot wheels car
sitting next to the sink in the bathroom
and then he knows that's what it means i
don't know rule number four ask the
magic question she was telling us about
when she went on a trip to africa where
the issue of concern was sex trafficking
of girls
she had been talking to a lot of people
doing a lot of reading speaking herself
as an expert
and rather than
going and telling people what they
should do to solve this problem
she asked the magic question
in a particular village she told us
about in zambia
she sits down with the village elders
and three girls in that village
had been sold by their parents in the
previous year
to sex traffickers
and she asks these village elders
what would it take
for those three girls not to have left
the village in that way
and they told her
an electric fence
an electric fence
they said the elephants are trampling
our crops of corn
and we don't have anything to eat these
girls they were starving
so gloria steinem goes back to the
states she raises a few thousand dollars
she sends it to this village so they can
put up an electric fence
she comes to visit again three years
later and the way she describes it
there's singing there's dancing there's
a bumper crop of corn and no girls have
left the village in that way since they
got the fence
the magic question
is what would it take
it's a magic question
because
first of all it empowers the other party
as the expert they are
it builds trust
they are the expert on their own
situation if you had been
studying this problem like gloria
steinem had you would never ever ever
have come up with a solution of an
electric fence right
at the same time it shifts the other
party from a judgment and
decision-making mode
to a problem-solving and collaboration
mode
and thirdly
it implicitly
has the other party committing to the
outcome
after they give you the roadmap if these
things happen
they are committed to
whatever it was that you're looking for
in this case it's the village elders
when they say what it will take is an
electric fence
it's not that magically an electric
fence keeps the girls in the village
but after they have committed to
what we need is an electric fence then
the elders also take action and make
sure that no girls are going to leave
the village now that they have an
electric fence also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
rule number five handle problems well
how we handle problems
is how we show our character
research has found something really
interesting
this is a pattern that happens only
sometimes it's an exception not the norm
but what can happen
when problems are happened exceptionally
well
is that a customer
or an employee
or a friend or partner
can become even more loyal afterwards
than they would have been had they never
experienced the problem rule number six
connect with confidence when i just ask
people what is the number one influence
skill you would like to master
and i don't even give them options the
most common answer is charisma so people
really badly want to be more charismatic
but then when i say okay what is that
yeah like well it's you know people pay
attention to you
okay but
why you can't be somebody like running
through the office in your underwear
that's not charismatic even though
people pay attention to you
but
so what i do
academic research i'm putting it to the
side because the leading model is a
seven factor model that you you it's not
something you can take action on right
you can't do seven things at once
what i do is organically figure out with
groups of people what is it that makes
individuals charismatic so i'll ask
someone and you've read this chapter ed
so it'll
um it's
it's not a
new thought or experience but i am
curious who in your life
out of all these charismatic people just
pops into your head as someone who
represents a charismatic individual
uh barack obama okay in person president
obama
by the way two or three of the
presidents that i've met now maybe their
stature
predisposed me to think that about them
their position but i did sense a certain
energy
connection
uh with them uh that the first person
that came to mind yeah and and power can
influence this also and so when you meet
barack obama
what how would you describe
say three traits if you can or three
behaviors that he does that has you feel
that he's charismatic deep listening
which you talk about in the book
unbelievable listening almost makes you
have the i'd like to think that i work
on this too that they make you feel as
if you're the only person that matters
in that moment
and that that you're valued and that
you're important i think that that's
a part of it and i think a tremendous
air of certainty
or presence confidence about what it is
they're communicating about they truly
believe
i often say sometimes that i think i
don't know that everybody always has to
believe what you're saying but they have
to believe you believe what you're
saying
be influential and i feel like those are
two of the characteristics when i think
of leaders that i've been around and he
would be one of them yeah so i feel like
this is kind of cheating because we sort
of teed up because you present this
chapter but this is also
listeners will know just
very directly probably true of someone
like obama having
the ability to connect
and display confidence are the two key
factors
for
being a charismatic person
and we can do both of those by
focusing our attention on the other
person instead of on ourselves and that
gives them the feeling of being the only
person in the room is that
deep
listening and connection and this is the
opposite of what a lot of people
just initially think of charisma as
being because we think of people being
charismatic when they're performing or
when they're speaking but it comes
through in that connection when they're
listening rule number seven do what's in
the best interest of others it's not
easy to say this is influence and this
is manipulation partly because
manipulation is a type of influence it's
just not the type of influence that i'm
teaching or espousing but but there's a
a pretty big gray area in between the
two and where a lot of so
there's plenty of manipulation that's
very obvious and plenty of
well-intentioned clear
um
influence that is you know just doing
good stuff in the world it's not
manipulative but where people get
confused in the middle often is
when i'm
trying to influence you
in a way that i'm
i want the best for you and for me and
i'm saying like hey vincent
let's do this project together or um or
maybe it's vincent could you give me a
job right and i i think i could do a
good job in that job but
or maybe it's vincent would you buy my
thing that i think that you will really
like
if there's something in the technique or
strategy that i'm using that i know
you
don't perceive
i might feel that that's manipulative
and this
when people are practicing influence and
learning these skills and developing
them
it's very very awkward because we know
that other people don't know all the
things that we're doing and we're honest
people
we're not trying to be dishonest
and then it also feels in addition to
feeling manipulative
it can feel inauthentic
because we haven't practiced it and so
it's like when you're learning a second
language or a third language and you
have to think
before you say
the words
so that the that inauthentic feeling
which is just a lack of practice
contributes to the question of am i
being manipulative and it
my simple simple answer is just going to
be are you trying to do something that
is in the best interest of the other
person as well as yourself and i don't
call that manipulative if you're trying
to do something that is
not
in their best interest and they don't
know what you're doing this is
manipulative rule number eight
understand how the brain works from the
gator brain perspective gator brain's
number one job is scanning the
environment for threats
and every time you are trying to
influence someone
you're a threat
a potential threat
you are a threat to
even if it's just their attention
or to their time
or to their social capital
sometimes it will be their money
any and
many many times you're a threat to their
autonomy
the gator brain hates to be told what to
do
we just hate being like when i shared
with you i was prohibited from playing
with barbies and becoming a marketing
person right my gatorade is like there's
my career path
this is the most famous graph in
behavioral economics and it's
illustrating what's called prospect
theory
and the
the basic message of prospect theory is
losses
loom larger than gains
we feel
a loss much more keenly than we feel
again and you know this from when you
get feedback right when you get 360
feedback or when you get feedback from
your boss you hear lots of great things
and they just kind of
go in one ear and out the other and then
you hear one piece of criticism and it
just it cuts right
bad is stronger than good
it's not bad that's just how it is
and it makes a lot of sense it needs to
be that way for us to survive
we have to
be a keenly aware of all of the risks
and all of the threats
so that we're not gonna make a mistake
rule number nine don't take away choices
when we're creating
environments for choice so it could be a
physical environment like a break room
or a cafeteria or it could be a sheet of
paper where you're making a decision
whether to donate your organs or
or join a 401k
everything that you do to create this
environment is going to affect people's
choices one way or another so you can do
it intentionally or you can do it
unintentionally when you're trying to
get people to join a 401k
nobody's saying that you have to so i
think the key thing is not taking away
choices and people get very upset
especially employees in a work
environment if you start to take away
options that they like like if you take
eminem's out of the break room then
yes you'll have social upheaval and
revolution and rule number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is find fulfillment in your job first of
all i don't want to take for granted
that um you can just leave your job and
follow your dream and you know say
you're a single mom trying to feed your
kids like my mom was when i was growing
up she couldn't just quit her job and be
an artist which is what she would have
wanted to do
but
what you can do is you can look at your
job and say where do i find the most
fulfillment and for a lot of people
who've been
working long enough to
um to lead teams of people
you might be selling bleach and maybe
you don't care about bleach
at all but maybe you feel great about
developing leaders and maybe you feel
great about mentorship and maybe you're
working in a company that's really
difficult right now people are
struggling and what you can do that's
meaningful is you can protect your team
from the forces above that are coming
down and threatening their well-being
all of the same skills that are useful
influencing people one-on-one are still
useful because groups are made up of
individuals
however
before you send your message it's really
important to strategize who are the
individuals that you want to recruit to
your team and build a coalition before
you get the broader message out so it'd
still be the same
skills or tactics of influencing people
one-on-one but you want to have some key
decision makers or opinion leaders or
key people that might be resisting your
message when you send it out broadly on
your side or at least have warning that
you're going to be trying to influence
the large group of people before you do
and if you can influence some of the
people that will be your biggest
detractors before you come out with your
broad message those will be the people
that will become your strongest
supporters because other people will be
looking to them and see what their
reaction is going to be
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there